Sáng 12, tháng 29, thêm phố Hà Nội tổ chức lòng rặt lễ hợi công bẩy giữa án công trình đầu từ xây dừng quý mô lớn,
tạo khi thế thí đưa suôi nổi, thế thực trọng mừng đại hội đại biểu tòan Quốc lần thứ 14 của đàn.
Đồng thời mở sát kỳ vọng về một giai đoạn phát trên mới của thủ đồ.
Theo kế hoạch, Hà Nội được lựa trọt là một trong những điểm cầu quan trọng của cả nước,
điểm cầu chúng tâm đặt tại giữa án đầu từ xây dừng khu đôi thị thẻ thao ô lìm biết,
kết lối trực dưới với Mỹ chính điểm cầu, các bộ ngành địa phương trên tòan Quốc.
Dìm cầu chính của thành phố được bố chỉ tại dự án đầu từ xây dừng chục đại lộ cảnh quan xong hồng.
Trong số các dự án được hợi công, khu đối thị thẻ thao ô lìm biết, có quý mô đặc biệt lớn với tổn mức lâu từ xưa bộ khoảng 27.000 tí đồng,
sựn tích hơn chính nghiên một trọng hết ta. Đình hướng phát trên thành tổ hợp thế thao lâu thị hiện đại,
lâu điều kiện đăng cai các sự kiện thẻ thao tâm châu lục và quốc tế.
Điểm nhấn là sinh vận động chống đồng, công chính có quốc gia,
sức trửa một trăm 8.000 diện trụ mối.
Cung dịp này, hà nội khởi công nhiều dự án hạt tần chế lược như chục đại lộ cảnh quan xong hồng.
Đến đường sách lâu thị sốn năm, tuyến kết lối xanh bài ra bình với thủ đồ,
cũng có sự án nhạy ở giá hội công viên tổ hợp thương mại dịp vụ.
Các công chính được ki vọng có phần túc đầy tăng chường gờ đếp về của thành phố,
tự năm hành in không trong hài sấu và các nằm tiếp theo đặt trên quế một phần chăm.